oh so it's my great pleasure to
introduce albert at sirius
uh albert is a professor at upc
barcelona he probably doesn't need any
introduction but i think
i will give one anyway he's a legend in
complexity theory
for many reasons he has two phds
one in proof complexity and another in
finite model theory i believe i got that
right
and in addition he has uh done
uh excellent work in uh proof complexity
descriptive complexity finite model
theory and
and building bridges between these areas
uh of uh complexity theory and logic
and he has won many many awards for his
work
um and today uh albert is going to talk
about
uh the past and present of descriptive
complexity theory so his take on
on the whole field so without further
ado albert the floor is yours
please thank you very much vijay for the
introduction
and thank you everybody for joining so
indeed i'm going to talk about
past and present of descriptive
complexity theory initially the title
had fitter but
i cannot predict the filter so i removed
that from the title
and many of the things that i'm going to
talk about are survey
and they don't include results of my own
in fact many of the things go back
to before the time i was born like for
example the turing machine
so my thesis in this talk is that
descriptive complexity is really one way
to see it
is by looking at the model of
computation in which we're doing
our algorithms so let's remind ourselves
what the turing machine is
so the turing machine works at the beat
level so it has a tape where you have
some
cell that is the current cell and then
the control has a set of instructions
and instructions that they do
the usual thing they read the symbol and
then they
do three things depending on what the
symbol is they rewrite the symbol with
another one
they move the head left or right and
they jump to another instruction in the
instruction set
now crucially the set of instructions is
a finite
set so this is a finite machine and it's
operating at the bit level
and for that reason many
typically mathematicians tend to think
that this is not a natural model
because it it doesn't have a
sufficient structure to be able to
analyze it
mathematically so but
in fact it's not the only model of
computation that works at the bit level
there is
a very closely related model in fact
which is the boolean circuit
and this is what shannon in fact very
early in 1938
this was his master thesis in mit
he called relay and switching circuits
and this is a remarkable paper where
he was talking about boolean circuits
and
essentially the way we we think of them
today so we have
some inputs that take boolean uh values
x1 to x5 in this example and then you
have some gates where you
do some obvious computation it takes two
inputs and produces another output
another bit as an
and so one way to represent this
computation here is by the set of
equations that you see on the right
so every gate gets a variable and then
you express what is the
effect of the gate on its image
and sharon himself analyzed the circuits
this way
and what this is what we call in the
satisfiability
uh literature we call it satan
transformation but maybe it should be
called the shannon transformation
because it shall
use this to actually reason about the
correctness and about
uh issues about the about the circuit
exactly
using boolean logic this way all right
so so these are two models of
competition they are extremely
they are very well connected one with
the other there are transformations
and from one to the other but
the the thing is that both are bit based
they are based on
working with beats and we now know and
we also already knew back in the 30s but
at the time and i mean the notion of uh
encodings was actually quite new and
this was one of the contributions of
getting that things can be encoded at
the bit level right
but we know that the data has structure
it's not
data is not just a bunch of bits so data
comes from something that we
want to understand and analyze such as
graphs it could be directed graphs or
undirected graphs
could be weighted you could have hyper
graphs where edges have more than
one verb two vertices you could have a
graph that have structure of a tree
partially ordered sets even casey net
formulas you can think of as
them as structured data so in this
example we have the clauses on the left
in this case three clauses and the
variables on the right you have a
bipartite graph
with two types of edges which denote a
current
and the occurrence were red could mean
for example that variable x1
appears in the closed in negative
polarity
and green would mean that it appears
with positive polarity
so even though kcnf formulas are quite
low level
representation of of data they are still
more structured than just plain bit
strings other type of data which
we might want to manipulate our matrices
which also have some structure
and we'll get back to it later again
so if data has structure then um why do
we break the structure completely and we
turn it into bit strips and
that that is actually a problem and this
was a problem that
at the beginning of database theory and
code realized that there was this
problem of how
databases are represented and he
introduced the model of relational model
of data the traditional databases
and this was as early as 1970 and the
model is the following
so it clarified
well it was a very clean way of
representing data
comparing to what was at the time this
was still before the time i was born
so i'm just reading from from the papers
so what is the relational model in the
relational model we have some relations
and this is your input
and what are relations well these are
just sets of tuples where a tuple
is uh a bunch of elements from different
domains
and these domains decide uh tell what is
the type of this relation this is how
it's called
so here is an example on the right you
have a bipartite graph you have two
types of vertices vertices
from some string domain and
vertices from some numeric domain and
then you have some relation between them
and that relation is the edge relation
in the bipartite graph
so in this example the three the three
relations would be
the set of vertices u the set of
vertices v
and the relation of h e itself
okay so so cod said
let's represent databases this way in
with relations and in fact he
he acknowledges that this goes back to
tarski
when he has this algebra of relations
and he introduces the concept of
relational algebra
and crediting a task for it so he says
okay what can we do with these relations
we can manipulate them somehow
some ways right so we can do
intersection of two relations provided
they are of the same type
you can do union of relations provided
they are of the same type you can do set
difference
we can do cartesian products what now
the types concatenate
and then there are two special
operations one is the selection
operation this is called
denoted by sigma i and j and what this
represents are the tuples in the
relation t where i and j component are
equal
this is the equal selection and then we
have projections where in projections we
have
again one component and what you do is
that you remove
the element in that component so you
take all the tuples in t
and you remove that component so we say
that we project
i out of the relation so these are the
operations the basic operations of the
relational algebra
and code suggested that with databases
represented in his relational model
uh data should be manipulated with this
sort of
uh operations so now we can
formulate what uh quote himself talked
called relational algebra expressions so
this is again like
some sort of a circuit it's written this
way to
to show the analogy so but now the
inputs are not bits but they are
relations themselves so the whole
relation is put as an input and you have
the basic operations inside
so these are expressions in this algebra
of
relations and again you can do the
intermediate
relations and and then you can measure
the complexity of the
expression by how wide these relations
are
how how many cartesian products we do in
this sort of
analysis that we could do good so these
are relational algebra expressions
and then um so god related uh this to
something quite familiar which is the
the first order logic on on uh
on a relational language so he noticed
and he proved that relational algebra
can compute precisely the same relations
from
from given relations it can compute the
same relations that you can
define with first of the logic
intersection corresponds to conjunction
union corresponds to disjunction
difference corresponds to indications
and this sigma this selection is the
equality relation which we
usually assume given for free and the
projection is precisely the existential
quantification
where now these variables range over the
domains
of our data model
by the way once you have negation and
existence of quantification you also
have
universal quantification one thing to
notice is that
relational algebra is variable-free
there are no variables
the uh there are no individual variables
so what
you're operating with these relations
directly in particular you're
not doing any choices so when when you
do an intersection
you apply the intersection to both
relations to every sample in the
interrelation
and when you do a projection you apply
the projection to every tuple in the
relation
you're not working individually with
elements or tuples of your structure
and this is important because
choice-free computation
is what we're after in domains like
databases and
in other places and that's a bit my
point here so
so before i go to to what descriptive
complexity brought
into the picture of complexity theory so
let me make a one comment which is the
comment
between uniformity and non-uniformity
one thing to notice in the difference
between boolean circuits and
relational algebra expressions is that a
single expression
or single formula can serve all inputs
of a given type
so here's an example if you want to
define for a given graph this
the vertices or the set of vertices that
belong to a triangle
and you have this single formula this is
a finite object with uh
25 symbols or something where you're
saying
x is in the relation that you're trying
to define if there are two vertices that
form a triangle
one of which is x yes so that's the
first order formula
and this single first order formula of
finite
set of symbols serves all input graphs
and these input graphs are now our input
relations
so in this sense it's a uniform model
but we could also imagine that we have a
non-uniform
computation where we could have for
example a different relational algebra
expression for
different input lengths this is an
approach that is actually quite useful
but it's not the one i'm following in
this and it's not the one
traditionally followed in descriptive
complexity so and
because of today i want to focus on past
and present of descriptive complexity we
are we're
going to focus on the uniform model this
thing are usually called queries
so this is a query on graphs they are
graphs because the types
are vertices and edges
very good so uniformity versus one
uniformity
and now comes the issue of computability
with relation so we have the
model of data and now we want to say how
do we compute with installations well we
already discussed the occupational
algebra
but is it powerful enough is this model
powerful enough
well ahoy mormon discussed this
and among many others actually around
late 70s and early 80s this was an issue
of discussion
but i think this quote here is a
pertinent given
woman's recent touring award so i think
let's see what um said the general
consensus
about the model of computation for
relations
is that one does not wish to have
general turing machine capabilities
so that's a bit funny thing to say uh
well you don't want to be
too incomplete so but there are reasons
for that and they go ahead and discuss
the reasons for it
and the reasons is these principles that
they
formulate that they say that uh
and we want this computation to be order
independent for example that's one thing
we want and what does that mean is that
well the way the relation is presented
to you the order in which the tuples are
presented to the machine
should not affect the output of the
computation and that's important for
databases for because you want
representation independence of your
queries i mean you want your queries to
depend only on the
truly structural data not on the
representation of the data
the second principle which is directly
quite related and it's a bit hard to
distinguish one from the other
but there is a bit of a difference is
the isomorphism variant
so here what what they mean here is that
if you rename the elements
then the output should only change up to
the
same renaming in particular and this is
an important point
if a structure if an input has a certain
automorphism
if you couldn't meaning that you can
exchange two elements in your structure
and not notice the difference
then the output should also have this
automorphism
so this is an important concept for
for preserving the abstraction that is
already in the input
and you want to preserve you want this
relational structure
okay so this model of computation
introduced or these principles
of the model of computation introduced
in the 70s
um was the guiding principle for
for for databases but then complexity
theory also had something to say here
and so fake instagram in fact is earlier
and effective still in the way it can be
interpreted this as a way to say that
the isomorphic invariant of the
iso-invariant
fragment of np coincides precisely with
existential second order logic
so what is uh what is existential
circumvent logic well you take
a first order formula where you have
some input relations and some
auxiliary relations that are quantified
existentially and this is
existential second order because this is
first order and this is the second order
and it's existential because you don't
quantify universally over second order
relations
so faking theorem is exactly this
statement that i wrote here
and what makes it an interesting
statement is that
the thing on the left is really a
semantic class
if you think of it as just by itself
because the fact that the
non-deterministic polynomial time
machine
computes an isomorphism in variant
property is not even a decidable
condition
and this is not something you can impose
on the machine by just
putting a clock for example the fact
that the machine runs in polynomial time
is not a decidable condition either
but you can enforce it by just putting a
clock
but here isomorphism invariant is not
something you can enforce by
such a simple device but in fact you do
you can enforce it because this is class
of existential second order logic is a
syntactic class
it's a syntactic meaning that the set of
formulas that you are allowed to use are
clearly
decidable set so so your devices are
the same okay so this is characterizing
a semantic class in terms of syntactic
class and that's what makes it
interesting
in one direction the reason it works is
that you have the power to
guess these existential quantifiers
and the other direction from from
machines to existential second order
project in fact
is nothing else than cook's theorem done
in
sufficiently abstract way so that you
preserve the automotives
good so this is fake instead it's
already covered so
let's move on so
here's the rule nobody likes zeus i
think
or a few people like zeus but i think
zeus
at least have a good thing it's that
at least they are not jungles right i
mean they are organized so
so here's what we call logic's zoo in
the same way that there is the
complexity class
so so let me give you a map of how to
write this
so down here we have complexity classes
from the complexity issue
and up here we have a bunch of logics
that correspond more or less to these
classes so for example
here in this cage this green
cage here we have np which is completely
characterized by existential second
order logic
and in fact this characterization can
also be done for the polynomial
hierarchy where you go to
full second order logic you could even
do it for p space and exponential time
by looking at proper that certain
extension of second order logic
albert yes can i ask a very naive
question
yes when you say that existential second
order logic is the same thing as
mp like np deals with languages and
whether strings are in languages so what
are our strings in our languages is it
like whether a structure somehow
satisfies a sentence or how should i
think about this
yeah good good question thank you so by
this what i mean is
the language encoding the relation so
the inputs are really relations but they
are somehow encoded
and now what i want to say is that uh a
language
so a collection of structures meaning of
relations
is accepted by your machine if the
encoding is accepted by
a certain machine okay so it's the
encoding itself but what you want is
that this machine is isomorphic variant
meaning that two encodings of the same
structure after isomorphism should be
accepted
both or rejected
so really the thing goes to encodings
and putting them as b as bit strings but
what you wanted
is that these encodings are either if
two encodings represent the same
structure
up to isomorphism then either both are
accepted or both are rejected
okay but i can think of this as like my
favorite np complete graph problem
what fagin says that there is like an
as logical sentence exists x and then
some phi
which sort of nails down exactly the
graphs that have this
property that make them yes instances
absolutely yes
okay yes thank you so much thanks to you
all right so here's my zoo again and so
let me
give you this thing so we have first of
the logic down here in existential
second order
here and we have um
okay so this question marks what do i
mean here well i have question marks
because we don't know of a logic that
corresponds exactly to isomorphism
invariant polynomial time
in the same way that we know our logic
that corresponds to isomorphism
invariant then b
we don't know one for polynomial time we
don't know one for
nondeterministic log space so it seems
to be that there is a dividing line
between p and np into the possibility or
at least as far as we know
today of uh capturing precisely the
isomorphism in varying fractions
of that complexity class for polynomial
time
it's the most attempt so i did this cage
quite long because i wanted to show the
fact that there
have been several attempts and the
arrows that have a cross means that it's
been proved that
they are not equivalent and the arrows
that don't have a cross mean that
they're just simulations so there are
two logics that are
particularly important the fixed point
logic and physical logic with calc
so fixed point logic with counting is
the focus that i want to give here
it's quite close to polynomial time in a
quite
clear sense and well understood so let's
let's get into that
all right so what is fixed point logic
first before they define fpc i need to
define fb
so fb stands for inflationary fixed
point logic usually
some people put an i in front
inflationary fixed point or fixed point
just for short
what do we have in this logic we have
the usual things we have inputs we have
equalities
quantification over elements in the
domains
boolean connectives and then we have an
inflationary fixed point
operator what is that well that's
nothing else than
iteration that's what i wrote here on
the left so i have the usual things
input selection projection
boolean combination and iteration so
what does it mean to iterate
well it's this very simple pseudocode
you start with the empty relation
and now you form the relation of tuples
that satisfy
psi given the current relation in this
case the empty set
and then while the new relation is not
equal to the old relation then you
iterate
you update the new relation and then you
update the new thing to be what you had
before
plus the new tuples that are satisfied
that satisfy psi so this way you get new
tuples
and you iterate until this converges
into some fixed points
and that that's what you operate
and one thing to notice is that because
it's inflationary because each time we
are adding new tuples this is going to
be
this is going to converge yes and in
fact it converges in time which is
polynomial
in the arity of the relation symbol r in
this case or x in this case
sorry polynomial in the size of the
input with exponent that is the additive
of this relation because there are no
more
elements to be added than that number
and now comes the inner man-party
theorem what you may have heard
which is essentially saying that the
deterministic polynomial time can be
captured by inflationary fixed point
logic except that there is a big if and
the big if
is that it requires the domains to be
ordered and
to allow this order on the relations on
the on the
domain elements so once you have this if
then this is no longer a semantic class
because isomorphism and variance becomes
trivial
because if the domain is fixed by an
order then there is nothing you can
you can permit within the same structure
other than just changing the names
so the automorphisms become trivial and
therefore it's no longer a semantic
class
still this is a powerful tool and in
fact we're going to see an application
of it
but it's not solving the question of
whether there is a logic for isomorphic
invariant p
so the question that we want to ask is
why do insist people ask why do we
insist
on order domains why is that so
important or for one thing fake instead
doesn't need this right while p seems to
require it at least as far as we know
today and therefore there seems to be a
fundamental difference here that we have
to understand
this was the problem of a logic for or a
language for isomorphic invariant p
raised by chandra and another thing is
that all problems of interest as i
already
argued are isomorphic invariant even
kcnf
ksat and this sort of things and
they don't depend on on automorphisms if
you flip two variables and that doesn't
change the structure of the formula it
stays this fire
another thing is that we want to look at
choice because
essentially having a linear order is
like having a choice you can always
choose the least element in the order
you want to think of it as a
computational resource in the same way
that
we think of random beads or quantum bits
as a computational resource and the
question
is how much of these this resource is
actually needed for
for efficient computation and the last
thing is that there is a program here
that
i want to highlight and and that was the
whole point of this talk
so before i get to the program i need to
say what is fixed point logic with
counting and why do we need counting so
one thing is that the
fixed point logic cannot do
basic arithmetic with the cardinality of
the structure for example it cannot even
tell whether the structure has an even
number of elements
this was recognized early on by
himmerman himself
and he said okay let's throw in one
quantification
that allows us to count in particular he
said
let's use accounting quantifiers of this
type where you say there are at least
i elements x that's at the side psi
but now i is a variable that ranges over
some special number domain
which we allow which we assume is given
in the input
and we allow some arithmetic on this
number domain the
whole point is that this number domain
and the other domain the domain of
actual structures are only connected
through these quantifiers
so there is no way to order the elements
in the in this
given instructor by the order that you
have in this
arithmetic because there is no way to
connect them one with the other you
don't have a
don't have a projection between them
so let me give an example of how you do
fixed point logic with counting you can
do quite sophisticated things this is a
basic one first
so let's count walks in graphs so
suppose we're given a graph on some
vertices
this is an adjacency matrix you can
think of it as 0 1 matrix with
indices the vertices of your graph now
how do we say that there is a walk of
length two
well that's the squaring of the matrix
so or rather
we want to count how many walks of legs
do we have so we sum over all w's or
intermediate points and then we take the
product right
one thing to notice that is that this is
isomorphic invariant if you permit to
w's
then because the matrix also permutes
then you're getting
you're getting the same count now once
once you can do paths of length two you
can do paths of
any power of two by iteration and this
is what you do with
the fixed point iterator but where here
i'm counting exactly i highlights saying
there are at least
i and there are not i plus one
so this is quite a powerful way to to
compute things
for example so here is the list of
things that you can do with
fixed point logic with counting you can
do connectivity queries this you can
already do with fixed point logic
you can do two sat you can decide
the satisfiability of a two cnn formula
you can decide whether a siena formula
has abundant width
resolution refutation for some fixed
width you can design horns that
you can execute unit close propagation
which is essentially the same as
horizontal ability
so these are things you can already do
with fixed point
once you add counting you can start
doing things like perfect matching or y
parted graphs
and you can do matrix non-singularity
over finite fields you can do algebraic
things you can also do determinants over
the rational numbers
you can solve linear systems of
equations you can do linear programming
you can do perfect matchings or general
graphs you can even do the ellipsoid
method
so it becomes a very very wide fragment
of polynomial time
for which we actually know how to prove
lower bounds
so it can do all this but at the same
time we can show that it cannot do
certain other things
but the focus of this talk is not on
lower bounds i would be happy to give
another talk
on lower bounds and adam foot first a
games and all that goes into them which
is beautiful results
but today i want to focus on upper
bounds so let me tell you how to do the
terminals for example
how do you do the terminals in a way
that preserves the isomorphism
of of the adjacency or of the matrix so
you have a matrix of rational numbers
and let's say they are zero one entries
just for simplicity they can be just any
rational numbers
think of an adjacency matrix now the
determinant of this matrix you can
you can express it by the usual formula
and if you look at it it happens to be
isomorphic invariant
that doesn't mean you can compute it in
polynomial time in isomorphic invariant
way
because that's an exponential big sum so
the question is whether you can compute
determinants of rational numbers
in fpc and here computing you what you
want is to compute the value
as a binary relation that as a relation
that equals the binary bits
the bits of them so one warning is that
gaussian elimination as a
this is a fantastic algorithm that is
used all the time it's not good for us
it's not the the choice the
choosing a pivot is not something we can
do because when we choose a pivot we're
breaking symmetries
so gaussian elimination is not available
but the nice thing is that there are
alternatives so level real method for
example
if you are in characteristic zero you
can express the determinant
i mean the characteristic polynomial of
the matrix
with a recurrence uh the coefficients of
the
characteristic polynomial can be
expressed as a recurrence that depends
only on the trace of the powers of the
matrices
but the powers of the matrices we
already said how to do in fpc
so it's available in fpc and the rest is
just the
recurrence of from a basic arithmetic
that you are allowed to do
in the fixed point logic
what about the trace well what the trace
is just the sum of the diagonal elements
and the diagonal is of course definable
because it's just the selection
of the entries of the matrix with equal
indices
that's exactly the so you select the the
the diagonal you add them up you add the
whole layer
that's expressible in fpc therefore you
can express the coefficients
and once you have the coefficients you
plug zero you get to the terminal of a
now i'm a bit out of time so no i don't
have time to discuss linear programming
it's a beautiful algorithm for doing
linear programming due to
anderson the warren holm it's based on
refining the ellipsoid method
i don't have time to discuss this
so it's a beautiful beautiful album so
instead of that let me
finish with a couple of slides of some
directions of fetal work that i think
could be done here
so there's a program here that one can
put forward which is
that okay we have this very big fragment
of polynomial time computation
it can do many things it cannot certain
things it cannot do like solving systems
of linear equations
over finite fields so that it can
it can do for characteristic zero it can
do for many other things
so it's a big fragment and now the
program is to prove the predictions that
complexity theory conjectures do
but do that prove it unconditionally and
by the predictions i mean that i don't
want i don't pretend to prove the
complexity theoretic conjecture itself
but whatever is predicted by this
objective so here is an example
so i put it in abstract terms that you
can complete you can put it
in concrete terms you need gapes
conjecture well let's put it in abstract
terms
conjecture x says that problem y is hard
okay
that's exactly what the unique game
projector says
so now you want to show that the family
z of algorithms so a huge family of
algorithms that you are interested in
things that come from proof complexity
things that come from
sum of squares algorithms whatever you
will have in mind you want to show that
this family of algorithms cannot refute
the conjecture x
and you want to do it unconditionally
because this is predicted by the
conjecture
so the way to do it is you show that the
algorithms in this family z
are definable in fpc and then by
reductions in the end you can show
that uh you can show that in fact
these algorithms cannot solve this thing
and therefore
and you did that unconditionally
now for the unique games conjecture
there is some initial work uh by
jamie tucker faults this is a very
recent paper that is very interesting
and it does
it doesn't solve the unique conjecture
for the algorithms of fpc
for but it makes some good progress for
hardness of approximation
like uh max threeside and max or and all
that we did it with another war a couple
years ago
and finally one last example that
connects to the
next talk is the following so
again within this program suppose you
want to prove lower bounds for a proof
system x
what do you need to do well one thing
you can do is show that the proof search
algorithm for this
restricted complexity proof search
algorithm for this
is expressible in fpc and in fact this
is one way
and joanna cremiak and her talk earlier
in this series
talked about this approach to proving
lower balance and this is precisely the
the topic that benedict pago is going to
tell us about in the next
talk so why would that be enough well
because your proof
so you want to say suppose that a
certain formula is
easy for system x well then
this fpc formula would be able to find
the proof because you're sure that the
proof search is too awkward in fpc
but on the other hand you know that some
formulas are hard
to distinguish in fpc from
unsatisfiable formulas are hard to
distinguish from satisfiable ones
so it could not have had a small proof
in the first place
so this way of proving lower bounds has
actually been put to work
and insist this is what benedict is
going to tell us about
so i'll stop here and i think i'm a bit
over time so thank you for your
attention
thank you albert for an amazing talk
questions please
i have a question go ahead or comment
so uh avitabul and vianu and me we
introduce a kind of an intermediate
model of relational machine
that in some sense it really tries more
to say how do we compute those relations
and without having to know logic so to
speak so you you basically says okay
suppose we have right programs
that that can use relational algebra
and then we are able to show kind of
tight connections to this to
to the logic yeah i'm aware of your work
in fact it was very excited at one place
but i was running out of time so i
decided to reflect to to go back to plot
and for relational algebra but i'm aware
of your model and uh
yeah it's definitely in fact in the
abstract i even talked about relational
machines and this thing this is your
your terminology relational machine yeah
you have a store
of relations that you're allowed to
manipulate
through basically a turing machine that
has instructions that say
what to do on the tape and what to do
with the relations
right right it's a beautiful model
it's useful has not been very
influential for some reason
there's a question by valentin
is there a non-uniform version of fmt
that can talk about circuits yes
absolutely this is an excellent question
and something i wanted to talk about too
so i i focused on on the uniform model
because that's how
most of prescriptive complexity in the
early times was developed
but the non-uniform model makes perfect
sense
and all the lower bounds in fact are for
the non-uniform model
so why is that so first of all what is
the model
the model is that now we have you can
imagine you have a fixed point formula
or
even first order formula doesn't matter
because you can look at
them as unrolled and you have one
different formula for each input like
input size so
for graphs of size 25 you have a formula
for graphs of size 26 you have another
formula
and the only condition you put on these
formulas is that they should all be
in size bounded by some polynomial for
example or some exponential
or some sub-exponential function and now
the lower bounds for proof com for
descriptive complexity they work in the
non-uniform setting
because the way they are proved is by
showing that you have two graphs
that look very similar and yet they are
indistinguishable by formulas of certain
size
or certain certain width to be more
precise
and that depends only on the size of the
graphs i mean you don't need to have
infinitely many graphs to play around
you have only two graphs of a certain
size and you play the rm voice again to
show that they are indistinguishable
and therefore you can construct infinite
families of such graphs one for every
input size
and therefore you get your lower bounds
now the thing is that the lower bound
you get is for circuits
that satisfy a symmetry condition they
are not arbitrary boolean circuits they
are
symmetric boolean circuits and this is
the topic of my talk
in a few weeks ago i gave in the seminar
and anushawar also gave a talk on this
concept of symmetric circuits
so we get lower bounds for non-uniform
symmetric circuits
exponential lower boundary
thank you any other questions so so i
had one question uh
if you may go back one slide or the last
slide where you
showed the the uh
yeah so i i'm trying to understand
what you're saying here so you're saying
that um
fpc is this restricted uh version it
doesn't completely characterize p
right it characterizes some large
fragment of p
and if you show that proof search
for a proof system x is easy by showing
that
proof searches in sfpc then that would
in turn imply that
uh the the
size lower bound on proof system x
basically basically that's what you're
saying
yes okay what's a bit confusing is how
can proof search be easy if they are all
hard
right they are all np hard more or less
well here because i'm thinking of proof
search for proof systems
like uh bonded with resolution there
that is easy i mean the only thing is
that depends on the parameter
so you have for with w you get time
n to the w but that's okay because we
have lower bounds that are exponential
so if proof search in end to the w can
be done in fpc with w variables that's
the
terminology that is being used so if you
can do it with w variables then a lower
bound for w variables will give you a
lower bound for
for with w so all of these things
actually match
very well i have one more question at
the very beginning of the talk
you mentioned that um the correspondence
between relations and first order logic
um and you said that the the relational
algebra that you showed there is
variable free
now this would be true for finite
relations right
is it also true for yeah yeah so i
forgot to say this is finite
relationship okay
yeah that's it yeah
it's final model theory it's finite
relationship all right okay yeah i mean
good well in fact this very relation
this holds for infinite ones as well but
for infinite domains but not everything
goes through
for example in this joule this is
quite interesting so least fixed point
logic and positively
fixed point logic so this is you don't
allow negations on the fixed point
operators
so these two things in finite structures
they happen to be equivalent
they are closed so we say that least
fixed point is close under
complementation
but for infinite instructors this is not
so so this is a theorem
of by immerman by the way it's a theorem
of finite structures
thank you very much that was a very
enlightening talk thank you albert
and that the very last slide actually
takes us
to the next talk by benedict so benedict
if you could share your
screen please
okay um so yeah benedict uh is going to
talk about a final
finite model theoretic view of
propositional complexity
allow me to uh just give a little bit of
an a bio of
benedict he's a phd student in eric
grill's group at
auckland university and he's going to
present this work that he actually did
as part of his bachelor's thesis
and he broadly works in the space of
descriptive complexity and finite model
theory so without further delay
benedict please go ahead yes thank you
um
yeah so this is a talk about this um
paper that i did a few years ago without
um and as the title says you know what
we did in this work was to establish
certain interesting connections between
finite model theory and propositional
proof complexity
and so what do these two fields have to
do with each other
so improve complexity um people study
proof systems so sets of inference rules
that allow to refute unsatisfiable
propositional formulas
and one main example of this is the
resolution calculus
and one is interested in the size or the
complexity of um
refutations depending on the formula
that you're refuting
and in finite model theory at least in
this context we're interested in
the expressive power of fixed point
logics on finite structures
uh yeah and albert has already said a
bit about fixed point logic so
these are extensions of first order
logics first of all logic that allow
um to express algorithms and iteration
and um yeah so when i say finite
structures you can always think of
graphs or colored graphs
or things like that um
and so how do we bring these two things
together
so it turns out that actually these two
formalisms so
proof systems and fixed point logics can
mutually simulate each other
provided that we use a suitable
translation between the two two worlds
so we have to somehow translate between
graphs and prepositional formulas
and then the simulation um preserves
complexity
uh so that's why um one of the main
applications of this
is that now we can transfer lower bound
results that are known already
between the two areas of research
okay so the overview of the paper and
of this talk is basically this so the
two proof systems that we studied were
the resolution calculus
and uh the so-called polynomial calculus
which is an algebraic proof system
and we related them to these um two
fixed point logics respectively
uh yeah and in the end i'll also tell
you something about the the lower bound
applications that i mentioned
uh so in particular how do we how can we
use known lower bounds from finite model
theory
to also get lower bounds for proof
complexity
um okay so let's start with the
resolution so this is probably
yeah quite well known um so this is a
standard proof calculus for
um refuting unsatisfiable
propositional formulas which are given
in conjunctive normal form so as a set
of clauses
and um cnf formula is unsatisfiable
isn't only if
the empty clause can be derived from it
using only this
resolution rule so we only have one
inference rule in this calculus
yeah and the rule says if you have two
clauses where in one of them you have x
and then the other one you have not x
then you can
unify the clauses and throw away the
conflicting electron
and this calculus is sound incomplete so
you can refute any unsatisfiable formula
but of course the refutation may be very
large in general because
uh if you always found it a short
refutation then the satisfiability
problem would be in p
or so so that can't be the case um
and so we want to measure the complexity
of a reputation somehow
and there are two let's say main
complexity measures
um one is the size of the refutation so
that's the total
number of clauses that you need and
there's also another way to measure it
namely you can look at the width so
that's the size of the largest clause
in a refutation okay so
so much for resolution and um
the logic that we related this to um is
least fixed for logic
or lfp and uh yeah as already mentioned
um this is an extension of classical
first auto logic
by a mechanism to express iteration
and this is done using um so-called
fixed point formulas
which look like this
and yeah they have a free variable and
um to express this fixed point iteration
uh we use a second order variable which
is r in this case
and so this can take as values subsets
of the universe of a structure and then
evaluating a fixed point formula means
that we have to form this this fixed
point
which is a yeah a sequence of um subsets
of the universe
and there is this update formula five
which says uh
how to update this fixed point in each
step so more precisely
uh the semantics is this so if we have
structure a
um and an element a small a from the
universe
then this satisfies such a fixed point
formula
if and only if this element a is in the
least fixed point
um of this sequence yeah so the sequence
starts with
the empty set as the value of r
and then the value of r i plus 1 is
always
the set of all elements in the structure
which satisfy the update formula with
respect
to the previous stage of the iteration
and i'll also show you
an example in a minute and essentially
one can prove that um
the sequence of sets that is defined in
this way is always monotonically
increasing
and at some point will always reach a
fixed point where it doesn't change
anymore
yeah and that's the least fixed point
and so this uh has well-defined
semantics and
um yeah can be used to express iteration
um yeah the expressive power of this
logic is
somewhere between that of first audio
logic and p time
so in particular all these fixed point
iterations will terminate after a
polynomial number of steps
um so when we relate this to um the
resolution calculus
it's already clear that we will not um
get
resolution in total but we can only
relate this to a fragment of resolution
where the proofs are guaranteed to have
polynomial size because otherwise uh
it's clear that we couldn't do proof
search in a p-time formalism
and um yeah to get a feeling for this um
yeah why there is this intuitive
connection between fixed point logic and
resolution we can now consider an easy
problem
as an example so um yeah this is the
reachability problem
on graphs so the input is just a
directed graph with two distinguished
vertices s and t
and the question is is there a path from
s to t
and it's yeah it's quite clear that this
cannot be um expressed in first order
logic because there is no mechanism to
to express transitive closures um but in
least fixed point logic we can
express this by the sentence that is
depicted there
um so the idea is we use this um second
order variable r
to stand for the set of all vertices
which are reachable from s
um and the fixed point update formula
says
in each step we add 2r each vertex
x which is either equal to s so that's
the base case
or which has a predecessor that is
already in r
and it's quite clear i think that this
um
the fixed point of this formula is
exactly the set of original vertices
so the computation proceeds as follows
so we start with the empty set
then at first we add the vertex s
because that's the only one satisfying
the update formula
and then we proceed by always adding the
successors so
this fixed point iteration essentially
simulates some breadth first search
in graphs you know like this and then
this is clearly the fixed point because
you can't add anything more
and then you see okay t is in the fixed
point so the formula evaluates to true
um okay so that this is the fixed point
logic view
on this problem um and now
it turns out that in resolution um
what happens if you encode this problem
in resolution
is very similar and somehow directly
simulates this fixed point induction
namely if we encode this
as a resolution problem uh the natural
way to do this would be
like this so we take a set of
propositional clauses
which is unsatisfiable if and only if
there is a path from s to t
and um so we use for each vertex in the
graph
a propositional variable and the meaning
should be that
the variable must be set to one if it is
reachable from
s so this is in fact the own formula
whose minimum model is the set of
original vertices
so for each edge we have such an
implication that says if the predecessor
is reachable then also the successor is
reachable
and in the end we have this not x t
which says um
yeah which is that so that the formula
is unsatisfiable if and only if t is
reachable
and um now the interesting thing is if
we review this formula in the
resolution calculus then somehow this
resolution
proceeds the same way as the fixed point
induction we saw before
so in the first resolution around so to
speak
we can get x v and x w meaning in one
step we can reach v and w
and then in the second round of
resolution then we can
obtain an xt and then we can
get the empty clause as well and so in
this case
yeah the clauses that we resolve
appear in the same order as breadth
first search would do in this graph
and as the fixed point induction
proceeds so in this example you see
that somehow resolution directly
simulates fixed point iteration
and now of course the question is does
this generally hold that you get this
nice
um correspondence and the answer is yes
but of course it also depends on the
encoding so
we should first of all say how we
translate this
this graph into a set of propositional
clauses
so you see in this example the set of
propositional clauses
is structurally isomorphic to the graph
somehow so
you have propositional variables
corresponding to the vertices
and the edges correspond to these
implication clauses
so this translation is extremely simple
and that's somehow what we want in
general
so to make this more formal
uh the way we uh we translate arbitrary
finite structures to cnf formulas
is via um so-called first order
interpretations
um and so if you don't know what this is
it suffices to think of it as a first
order definable mapping
between finance structures so that means
the elements of the image structure
correspond to tuples of elements of the
original structure
and the relations in the image structure
are first order definable in the
original structure
and most importantly this means that
computing this reduction given by such
an interpretation
does not require any computational
overhead so you don't need recursion or
fixed point induction
to compute this and that's why this is
somehow the natural choice of reduction
that we use here
um because we really want that this
fixed point iteration is simulated by
resolution
and not by the reduction that is in
between these two words
yeah so um the way how we simulate fixed
point formula in resolution
is we apply such an interpretation
to the input structure for the fixed
point formula
and this gives us a cnf formula that we
can use as the input for the proof
system
and of course this means that the cnf
formula is again represented as a graph
or a finite structure
but the concrete representation is not
relevant so this is clear that this can
be
done somehow um okay and with respect to
this notion of reduction
we get all our correspondence theorems
between proof systems and
fixed point objects yeah so this is the
first result
namely that lfp corresponds to
resolution on whole formulas
so in detail one direction is that for
every
fixed point sentence there is a first
order interpretation that just depends
on that sentence
which takes finite structures to hold
formulas
such that the structure is a model of
the fixed point sentence
if and only if the whole formula that
you get is unsatisfiable
yeah so this shows indeed the evaluation
of 6.4 million formulas um
can be done by resolution on horn
formulas
and the proof for this goes um via
certain model checking games
for these fixed point logic so um yeah
i won't go too much into detail but one
can show or it is known that
on finance structures checking whether a
fixed point sentence is true
reduces to solving yeah so-called
reachability games
and this is very similar to the to the
example of the reachability problem that
i already showed you
so in fact this can be encoded as a home
formula and
that can be refuted in resolution and
the other direction is also true so it's
not so difficult to write down a fixed
point sentence
which exactly expresses that a whole
formula has a refutation
um because the complexity of phone
resolution is
quite low and as i already said
this process of iteratively resolving
new courses
can be seen as a fixed point process
itself so
yeah this is why it's true and maybe
more interestingly
with the same reasoning you can also get
results for bounded width resolution
so this is the fragment of resolution
where the width of the course is bounded
by a constant
and this corresponds to a strict
fragment of
called existential lfp um
this is like lfp but now the fixed point
formulas may not contain universal
quantifiers
and this is also known as stratified
data log by the way
yeah and so this um weaker version of
fixed point launcher can be simulated
using only width 3 resolution
and conversely for any k width k
resolution can also be expressed
in this fixed point logic again because
if the width of the clauses is at most
constant
then the proof size is guaranteed to be
polynomial because there are only
polynomially many
clauses you can resolve
okay yeah so this finishes the case of
resolution and now
we go one step further and um
look at an algebraic proof system and
this means on the side of final model
theory that we add counting
so yeah albert has already talked about
this
um fixed logic with counting is simply
the extension of lfp by so-called
counting terms
um yeah we won't go into the details but
essentially
this means you can now count the number
of satisfying assignments for formulas
and the expressive power of this logic
is
between lfp and pe so this is strictly
stronger than lfp because one can show
that lfp cannot count
and this is sort of the fix for that um
yeah
and the evaluation of these formulas is
still in p time
and yeah it's a fragment of p um
and one should say that from the point
of view final model theory this is
an extremely well studied and important
logic
so many combinatorial algorithms can be
expressed in this logic
and therefore it's it's interesting to
relate this to a group system
and the proof system that corresponds to
it is the polynomial calculus
and this is now not really a system for
for a propositional satisfiability
problem
but instead the problem is this so
the input is always a set of polynomials
and they are multilinear so that means
they are multivariate polynomials but
each variable
has an exponent at most one
um and the question is does does there
exist a zero one assignment to the
variables
that is a common zero of all these
polynomials
um so in this sense um it's also kind of
a propositional problem because
we treat the variables as propositional
variables in a sense
um and now there is a derivation
of the one polynomial from this input
polynomial set
if and only if this system of
polynomials is unsatisfiable
so meaning if there is no common zero
and so the proof rules are just these
two so
first of all you can take arbitrary
linear combinations of derived
polynomials
um here i should say that the
coefficients come from some
some field that you have to fix
beforehand so you can do this over
different fields and depending on the
field that you choose
you actually get a proof system with
different power
yeah but okay so this is the linear
combination rule and the second rule is
you may multiply any polynomial that you
have
with a variable from the variable set
and as an example let's say we have two
polynomials
x y minus one and x and you can see that
there is no common zero
because yeah if you have to set x to
zero
but then also x y is zero so the first
polynomial is then minus one
so there's no way to make them zero at
the same time
and therefore there should be a
derivation of the one polynomial
and this is easy in this case so um
first of all we can multiply
the input polynomial x with y then we
get x
y and then using the linear combination
rule we can um
yeah take x y and x y minus one and get
the one polynomial
yeah so in this case this works and this
also works in general so this is again a
sound and complete proof system
but again the size of the refutations is
what's interesting here so
a quick question can you go back as well
can you go back one slide uh so the
variable
x with which you multiply the polynomial
f must
not already the must not already
appeared in that visit
uh yeah it usually should be um from the
input
i think you can also consider different
settings but uh yeah
here we consider only variables which
already appear in the input polynomials
would it not then give you like a
quadratic
um if f contains x already would you not
get x squared
and i thought that was um yes i
didn't mention there's always implicitly
a rule which allows you to
which says something like um x squared
minus x
equals zero so you can always remove
these um
these squares with an extra proof rule
that always exists
okay yeah
um okay and so the complexity is
either again the size of a refutation
or correspondingly to the width in the
case of a resolution
you can consider the maximum degree of
any polynomial
that you derive
and one can say also the characteristic
of the underlying field over which you
do all this
also affects the complexity so there are
sets of polynomials which are easy to
refute over
a certain finite field but require a
very large refutation of the rationals
for example
but in this setting we always consider
the rationals as the field
and one thing that is very important to
know is that
bounding the degree has an effect so
if we bound the degree by a constant
then all this becomes algorithmically
tractable
so you can exhaustively search for
proofs
in the k degree polynomial calculus in
polynomial time
and this is essentially due to linear
algebra so um
the set of all derivative polynomials is
always a vector space
due to this linear combination rule and
so if the dimension of the vector space
is polynomial then
we can apply the so-called group basis
algorithm to solve this
so the trick is that we don't have to
explicitly derive all polynomials that
we could derive
but we can always only consider a basis
of that space
and therefore this is tractable in p
time
and this is also part of the reason why
this theorem
holds that we got um
yeah namely the polynomial calculus
of bounded degree corresponds exactly to
fpc
so on final structures we can simulate
any fpc sentence
in the polynomial calculus of the
rationals already in degree
two and for any constant k we can also
exhaustively search for proofs in fpc
um again over the rationals
and yeah the proof so going from fpc to
the polynomial calculus is again via
model checking games
and these are now sort of reachability
games um
with counting so now not only the
existence of a winning strategy or of a
winning move
is important but also um the number of
winning moves that you have in a given
position
but these kinds of games can be solved
in the polynomial calculus if you use
a suitable encoding and for the other
direction
i already said there exists this grip
basis algorithm
which exhaustively searches for proofs
and in case of the rationals we can
implement this in fpc
because yeah i think albert also
mentioned this that linear algebra over
over the rationals is somehow doable in
fpc
but for finite fields this is not
possible so this theorem really um
is only possible of the rationals
uh yeah so this is the overview of
results so we saw these three variants
of fixed point logic
in increasing expressive power and up to
these first order reductions they are um
equivalent to these proof systems and
what's maybe funny is that um
on the proof system side we considered
resolution and the polynomial calculus
which are two completely different
systems but on the final model theory
side this just corresponds to adding
the ability to count to fix my logic so
somehow
polynomial calculus is like resolution
with counting you could say
okay so now there's still this part
about the lower bounds
so the main goal here was to transfer
well-known lower bounds from finite
model theory to proof complexity
and um so for this we still have to
specify how we measure complexity
in finite model theory and here we say
the complexity of a finite structure is
simply
the number of first order variables
required to identify the structure up to
isomorphism
and this is a bit sloppy but essentially
you can always ask yourself so what's
the least complex first order sentence
that
uniquely describes the structure
and with this complexity measure you can
also write two structures
a and b are k equivalent if they cannot
be distinguished by any k variable
sentence
where sentence refers to fixed point
logic now
or also first order logic
and the idea is that if we have two
structures for which we can prove that
they are sufficiently similar
so k equivalent then this also carries
over to the
corresponding um propositional formulas
that we get
using nfo interpretation so then also in
k
width resolution or k degree polynomial
calculus
the corresponding formulas are
indistinguishable so either they both
have a refutation or both don't have a
refutation
now because if they were somehow
distinguishable
in the proof system then using these
simulation results
um it would follow that they are also
distinguishable in fixed point logic
but this is not the case and you know so
this is the the argument here
and maybe the main example for that we
got lower bounds for
or reproved lower bounds for um is the
graph isomorphism problem
um so here you can exploit yeah standard
constructions from final model theory
so the so-called cfi construction which
we can read as a black box now
but it yields sequences of uh yeah
non-isomorphic graphs of increasing size
but the fact that they are not
isomorphic is very hard to tell from the
point of view of logic so
they require a linear number of
variables to be distinguished in fixed
point logic
and if we use these graphs and take any
interpretation that maps them
so maps pairs of graphs to propositional
formulas that express the existence of
an isomorphism
then using the reasoning that i already
mentioned
um we can infer that the width or the
the degree
that is required to refute um the
corresponding isomorphism
um yeah formula is at least linear
because otherwise if it were a sublinear
then these structures could also
be distinguished in fixed point logic
with a sublinear number of variables
and from this one immediately guess that
the size of the proofs is at least
exponential because
this is a well-known relationship from
proof complexity that
the size of a proof is always
exponential in the
in the width or the degree um yeah and
all this is not you
so these things uh had already been
known these lower bounds
um but now we have this yeah unifying
framework for proving them
and also this is more independent of the
encoding of the graph isomorphism
problem because
our results hold for any encoding up to
first order interpretations
and lastly one can say that also other
lower bounds from proof complexity can
be reapproved
using these methods so for example
well-known exponential lower bounds for
resolution and for pigeonhole principle
and the three colorability problem for
graphs um
yeah can also be now inferred from
finite model theory
yeah so that's it thank you benedict for
a fantastic talk
thank you questions please so for
pigeonhole and three colorability you
can't get anything for uh
that would translate into polynomial
calculus lower bounds
um i don't think that we did this but
uh that should probably also work yes
other questions pablo i have a question
yeah i have a question uh vijay yeah
please go ahead
so albert and with focus and i have
looked to define something called
csp proofs consent satisfaction proofs
and in some sense the closing to file
model theory because you're really
working more directly with relations
there
and you could define the notion of
bounded with proof which
i don't know if i don't think we define
it but you could define easily define
the context of
of a bonded with proof there
and would be interesting to see i don't
think so the relationship there again to
to to lfp has not been worked but it
would be interesting to see how
it fits in this picture
ah okay so what do you mean i think i'm
not aware of this work
i'll i'll send you a pointer later yeah
okay thank you yeah
there are two questions in the chat uh
antonina asked the question in the paper
you mentioned a normal form
for the structure used in the last proof
could you say a bit about it
[Music]
you can unmute yourself and ask the
question but are you referring to the
graph isomorphism
uh i think to remember that in one of
the proofs you define
the norm uh
operating you talk about normal forms of
the structure
and that allows you to get around the
cfi construction
and um i was i found it very interesting
that you could say something about it
that would be
great
has a question is there a relationship
between the resolution width and the
additi
fixed point operators in here
well there's certainly a relationship
between the number of first order
variables that you use in this formula
but
um between the arity
yes probably probably too because
i mean the arity of these fixed point um
operators somehow corresponds to the to
the resolution with
in the in the natural way when you
simulate it
um but i don't know if you can um
formally show this uh yeah
igor oliveira asked is there any hope
lots of questions actually
hope that stronger proof systems can be
captured in this way
um beyond uh yeah so i tried this
to extend this to um
so i don't know if you know the logic
choices polynomial time so
that's another extension of um fixed
point logic with counting which is
um strictly stronger and i tried whether
this logic can also be captured by a
proof system in this way
but that only worked in one direction so
the proof system that um
somehow corresponds to this is um
extended polynomial calculus so that's a
version of polynomial calculus where
still the degree is bounded by a
constant
but you may use extra variables in the
proof to abbreviate um high degree
polynomials
in some sense and that's a stronger
improved system but
it does not correspond to the choice's
polynomial time in both directions
so i don't know if this nice
correspondence really works for
for stronger proof systems as well yeah
maybe not a couple of more questions so
massimo lauria asks
there is a map from width k resolution
to lfp and
llfp2 with three resolution
but width three is weaker than width k
is there something going on in the
encoding
similar for the polynomial calculus um
yeah this is because uh the encoding is
um yeah why are these first order
identifications
and so basically this width
gap is somehow hidden in the
in yeah in the reduction between um
going back and forth between final
structures
and these encodings um
so the first order interpretation
basically does the
bridges the gap between the width
thomas cochman asks uh you mentioned
on unsaid how about on sat which is p
complete
the left piece simulates on unset and
lfp is
strictly weaker than p so horn and sat
is strictly weaker than onset
um wait aren't on unset
and horns are the same
um yeah i don't think i can answer this
directly sorry
pavel has the question how do you prove
the lower bound on the pigeonhole
principle
formulas the formula has large width
um yeah you take structures
which so you take some audit structures
which essentially encode the pigeonhole
principle
and then you have to show that
the structure that corresponds to
mapping end pigeons to n holes
and the structure that corresponds to
mapping n plus one pigeons to n holes
that these structures cannot be
distinguished using less than n
variables
in first order logic okay but uh
what i don't understand is you said that
you use
width and degree to get the size
lower balance so in the case of the
of the general principle uh
you cannot do it directly because the
the width of the formula itself is
already large
right right that's true oh okay oh yeah
i see what you mean
um okay then i would have to check that
again
uh if that's even i'm correct
quick question benedict were you able to
prove any new
lower bonds that were not previously
known like new classes of formulas
um no so at least not so far another
question from massimo
is there any law
is there any lower bound infinite model
for random structure
um
what would random structure mean though
i would really like to get such lower
bounds for pc
uh i can improve myself yes go ahead
please
i mean i for example we know
for a lower bond for tricolor ability
for resolution of random graphs
we don't know lower bound for tricular
ability
for a random graph we only know for
specific worst case constructions
so if we could prove
a lower bound for tricolor ability over
random graphs
uh for example in the fpc
then i i would understand that we would
get
a lower bound for run for random graph
in polynomial calculus oh
yes um i mean i have looked at this but
um this might be worthwhile to think
about then
so you're saying um there is no known
lower bound for random graphs
for three colorability for the
polynomial calculus or
no only for resolution i mean the
tricolor ability k color
i i i don't know the number precisely
but if you take a random graph
around or around on the regular graph
that would be hard the first sort of
uh d over log d colors i mean
you you have to basically choose the
number precisely
but somehow you have hard instances for
tricolor ability
if you take a random irregular graph for
the right value of the
say and okay so yeah if one pound such
graphs
in the resolution we know uh we know
these lower bounds
but we don't know them for uh polynomial
calculus
okay so maybe it would be a way to go to
try and find such graphs that that are
hard to distinguish in fixed point logic
[Music]
that's cool thanks for that question
massimo all right
thank you again benedick for a great
talk and oh albert you have a question
please go ahead
just a comment on the random graph thing
but usually random graphs tend to be
rigid and they don't have automorphisms
and therefore
and even what tends to happen is that
you can define a linear order on them
with the logic and then the lower bounds
tend to break
on the other hand there is a
construction known as the multi-pitch
construction
which is a random construction and it
gives lower bounds for
fpc so this is this is due to good
eviction
and it has not been yeah
it's something to look at i know exactly
why you're asking this maximum and i
think it's a good question
yeah thank you again uh thanks
for a great talk benedict um so uh
antonina can you please share your
screen while i
introduce you so now it's my uh
great pleasure to introduce antonina
kolokolova
uh antonina is one of those
theorists who is interested in many
different things not only proof
complexity
but also in the practical side of
you know solvers for example so i've had
the pleasure of working with her on
many papers together and she's also
interested in
the connections between theory and
neuroscience she's well known for her
work
in proof complexity and she did her phd
under the supervision of stephen cook
and is currently a professor at memorial
university of newfoundland
so without further ado antonina please
go ahead
thank you so much for the nice
introduction vijay
okay so um
and uh thank you so much albert and
benedict for spectacular talks it was so
cool to listen to you
[Music]
okay so uh what i'm going to talk about
is one more line of connections kind of
in the opposite direction
from what benedict talked about
not from proof complexity into
um finite model theory
well with proving things and going back
but
uh how we could take
results in descriptive complexity and
actually build reasoning systems on top
of them
so basically uh we have
uh kind of three realms in which you
talk about
problems one of them is the search
problems
for example how hard it is to find the
path in the graph
another one uh the one that you've just
heard a lot about
is express a power what does it take to
say
that the graph is connected
but at the third side the one that
showed up more improv systems
what does it take to prove properties
for example that
reachability strategy
and the loosely speaking
those three realms would be your classic
algorithm
complexity theory descriptive complexity
and type model theory
and for the probability of
proof systems as well as its uniform
counterpart
bounded arithmetic and you've seen a lot
about the
relation between complexity
and the defined model theory today
descriptive complexity you've seen
some of translation from proof systems
into descriptive complexity in
benedict's talk
and actually next week uh in this
workshop next wednesday we are going to
have a session
on um kind of mathematical foundations
of that with stocks going
more into arithmetic and um
probability and that side of thing so
what i want to talk about today
is
is how uh results proven
in bound in descriptive complexity
setting
can let us build something
in
let us build reasoning systems
so it's this direction
so um just one caveat
that uh here i'm just going to talk
about the uniform classes and uniform
system
there was a really nice question about
non-uniform side of finite model theory
but what i want to focus on today is
actually uniform side of finite model
theory because to me
in a way some of those characterizations
that albert talked about are uniform
counterparts to
what we think about as a propositional
satisfiability problem
and friends and in fact um pagan theorem
is kind of a counterpart
of cook's theorem where rather than
getting a class of formulas
you just get one formula uniform setting
so um and another thing maybe
uniformity we will be talking about
uniform classes even for very small
classes so we could talk about the class
uniform a deluxe time uniform ac0
which has a very direct connection with
first order logic
so more precisely uh
and i will define those things um
what i want to show today is how you
could start with
um logics in particular fragments of
second order logic
this nice descriptive complexity
characterization
and use them to build theories
with the same power
and the show what exactly
you need to get theories of the same
power from those characterizations
so you just heard albert stock
and he was talking about the
groundbreaking
result in 74 of um
uh ron pagan who've shown um
that np corresponds precisely to
existential second order and the proof
is again a variant of
hook theorem except rather than
generating a different
formula for different
input and randomly turing machine
you actually have just one formula
defining
the tableau of the computation
and the this allows you to be
in a setting where you could actually
talk about one
formula specifying a problem as opposed
to a family
of problems so for example in proof
complexity we often talk about pigeon
pole principle as a family
but here pigeonhole principle is just a
single formula
okay so um
vegas characterization shows that
without any assumptions on the
underlying structure
np corresponds to existential second
order formulas
in 91 regradle extended it
to show that subclasses
of second order logic in particular
second order logic
where the formulas are of this form
also correspond to
well-defined complexity classes on
structures containing successors so in
particular
if you take existential second order
formula
of this form and you restrict
the formula to be a horn formula
uh where i guess the horn with respect
to those
p1 to pk predicate then
on successor structure this logic
captures
exactly polynomial time and when you
restrict the formula to b2cnf
uh you could capture nondeterministic
log space and actually he had
characterization for symmetric workspace
for workspace
it's uh it's really beautiful piece of
work
can you uh define what you mean meant by
um horn over
the predicates uh so i just mean
that it's a cnf formula where
every clause has at most one positive
occurrence of a predicate
okay got it so you only consider those
as occurrences of the predicate as your
variables
to say and then it's horn with respect
to that
so another result uh by
barrington immerman and strobin might
have been
some earlier results by immerman but
barrington
strobing gives a deluxe time uniform
characterization
shows that if you don't have second
order quantifiers
then uh you just have first order logic
with three second of the variables
then you capture exactly the class
ac 0 the class of bounded depth circuits
which is probably the smallest
complexity class
that you hear people talking about
and the beauty of those
characterizations is that
the correspondence is exact if you prove
the two logics are equivalent the
corresponding classes are and vice versa
so as albert was showing there are lots
of techniques that can be applied in
this setting
to prove something about logic and then
transfer it
well to proof systems and so on
so in proof complexity
we tend to be more interested in
proving tautology so proving some
statement
rather than expressing statements
and the natural question is
if you are operating with a class of
formulas
with precisely defined complexity can
you say something about the complexity
of
reasoning with those formulas
and um actually to me it goes
way back to the time when i was
undergraduate
and i came to tony pitasi uh
asking to do some research with her and
she gave me two papers one of them was
ron fagan's uh finite models theory
personal perspective
and another one was some buses notes
on bounded arithmetic
so i read them very excited came to tony
and say
tony so how do those two how are those
related
how do you go from one to the other
there must be a connection
well i'm still stuck thinking about the
connection many many years
after
so let me just mention very few things
about the
history of the arithmetic side of it
and next week we are going to have
several talks
that will cover this much better and in
much more detail
by uh sasha rasbora pavel pudlak
and shy bien david so
i won't spend too much time on it but uh
basically um piano arithmetic is
probably one
theory that people think about when they
think about um
power of reasoning in um
power of reasoning in systems unless you
do
bound uh at least you do reverse
mathematic or something like that piano
is making is one of the default theories
that we written about
and um later on
people have defined uh so but um indian
arithmetic is very strong
it talks about things from computability
real
rather than complexity really um in
order to move things to
closer to the efficiency question parikh
defined the bounded version
of a piano arithmetic i delta zero
but this time it ended up being serious
a little bit too weak you just talk
about linear time hierarchy and you
can't quite go beyond it
then steve cook have defined the theory
pv original as an equational theory
which was designed to capture polynomial
time
exactly he used kobun's characterization
of polar melting recursive
characterization
to just define
polynomial time functions and operations
with them
and they theory would later extend that
it's thing by criteria to make
uh to add a bit more blind stuff
and um probably one of the main
defining works in this area
is sambas's beautiful thesis called
bounded arithmetic
where he defined um
well he defined a lot of different
theories
corresponding uh to various complexity
classes
and proved very interesting witnessing
theorem
that has prove that when you can prove
something
in theory then you know the
complex if you prove an existential
statement in this theory
with certain form then finding a
business
can be done by an algorithm of specific
complexity and the algorithm kind of
falls out of the proof
so uh well in bounded arithmetic just to
say
uh what makes it bounded is that the
thinking of
all values that are quantified as
uh bounded by the terms in the three
variables
and here when i'm talking about the
power of a serial
arithmetic especially in the
correspondence with
complexity classes it's basically what
kind of functions
can be
probably defined in the system by
um
can be defined in this system so the the
system
rules there exists unique value of the
function
and just one caveat that
it can very well happen that there are
theories that capture
the same class of functions
that is a proof totality of the same
class of functions
and yet one system seems to be more
powerful than
another system as in
it's not believed to be that everything
every theorem that one system proves can
be proved in the other
so relating this back to prepositional
proof systems
there is actually a very direct
connection
because uh for those kinds of theories
for one direction you could do
you could do direct translation in
propositional proof systems
by taking theorems
of the cis of the theory converting them
into your family of pathologies
and showing that the corresponding proof
system can prove that family of
pathology
and for the other direction uh you could
show that
the bounded arithmetic theory can prove
essentially soundness more precisely
reflection principle for the
corresponding proof system
so even though um bounded arithmetic is
a kind of a uniform setting and proof
systems are non-uniform there is a very
tight connection between the two
and uh just to mention that you
the theory that captures
ac0 would give a translation directly
into ac zero fragment bounded that's
trigger
similarly a theory for um nc one will
give you
frag and the theories for polynomial
time they translate in this way to
extend the threat
okay so
let's now connect the descriptive
complexity down
about the arithmetic side by showing how
you could
build a theory of arithmetic and if you
have never
seen a theory of arithmetic or built one
hopefully this would be a kind of a
gentle introduction to one way of doing
it
so what we need in the cod we need a
language
and we need axioms and here
we are going to take a slightly
different
path from uh what sambas did in his
thesis
and use a two-sorted theory which will
have a much better correspondence to the
descriptive complexity characterization
what i mean by two sorted is that you
have two kinds of objects
you have numbers and you have strings
just like
in distributive complexity
characterization you have your
graphs predicates as being the
second order object so to say floating
rounds
here you will have strings corresponding
to
the structures
the axioms of the theory
would be fairly standard first of all
for numbers we'll just take
the very classic axioms defining how
plus and time separates and here we just
need plus and times
for example axiom saying that
for any x x plus one is not equal to
zero
and and stuff like that
one is greater than zero and so on
then for strings we will have very few
things
again we want to look at them as
predicates so
uh we will just say um
we will just use an operator telling us
what the bit of a string
is and we also define what the length of
the string is because we want to
kind of bounce things so we want to say
can you hear me i can hear you clearly
antonino
uh is there anybody else who wants to
just say that
whether they can hear i can hear you
okay
thank you so i guess thomas is having
some problems there
and maybe it's yeah
okay
okay so um
in addition to those basic actions
saying what you could do with strings
and what you could do with numbers
well add and multiply numbers and take a
length of the string and look up a bit
there is one more axiom and this is
this will be the main axiom that will
let us define all sorts of different
theories and basically what this axiom
is saying
is that if you have a formula
from some limited class of formulas
then you could get a characteristic
string
of that formula
that's really the only thing that we
need to build the theory
and now uh we could reason with those
axioms and in order to do reasoning in
order to do proof
uh you could take your favorite way of
doing proof
i think uh genson's uh calculus lk
is the most standard underlying way of
doing proof but
there is really um so uh
can i ask you a quick question x of y
what is what does that notation mean is
x is string here and
y is a number uh yeah it just uh
uh the wise bit of x when x is treated
as string
okay so you're saying if i
take the white bit of x then it implies
y must be strictly you kind of interpret
one as a true
and the zero is a false
so uh another way of thinking about it
is x is a set and
x of y is whether y is in the set x
i see you see okay
and uh comprehension you're saying there
exists a string
x x is a string variable
uh i'm trying to is less than or equal
to
n so i guess the bit strings
here are being interpreted as numbers
implicitly
um well the strings are strings uh
numbers
uh are mainly used to
um talk about lengths and indices yeah
but but
what do you mean there exists an x less
than or equal to n what is
sorry i didn't define this notation uh
so
thank you so much so what i mean is
length of x
less than equal to n okay so there
exists an x such that
length of x is less than or equal to n
for all
integer variables or natural numbers
z less than n
so now if z is in the set x
i see cc okay
all right
got it but here but here
phi is a formula in this language or is
it a formula of over arithmetic
it's a formula in in whatever restricted
class of formulas uh we define
and the power of the theory will
correspond to the power of that class
formulas okay
yes thank you more questions comments
nope please go ahead
so um one thing that you might be
wondering is
uh there is induction because in piano
arithmetic and pretty much pretty much
all the other theories that i've seen
vast majority of them you have an
induction axon in fact you could
actually for all the theories that we
care about
prove induction but uh just don't
just to have it to make life easier
here it is uh given a string you could
do
uh induction on the length of the string
so if something
um if x of 0
well if element 0 is in the set x if you
want to think about it as set
and uh for every y if y isn't
the set x then y plus 1 is then
n is in the set x here's your induction
on the length of the string
so this is really all you need to build
the theory
and you don't even need induction and
now
with those theories you could
prove theorems you could uh
define functions and proof totalities of
the functions
you can convert them to proof systems
and so on
so um what kind of theories do we get
when
we do it for different so what defines
the power of the theory is really
what class of formulas we are allowed
the theory is allowed to talk about
so um first of all if we take
um other class of formulas
um existential second order and here
um i'm treating the second of
order objects in the descriptive
complexity stating just
as strings inbound the terimagic setting
but this really doesn't matter the
translation
the translation pretty direct so if you
take existential second order you get
the logic for np predicates and
if you make a theory out of existential
second order
you make a theory that can talk
about um well things definable by np
predicates
and in particular you get
you directly get two sorted analogues of
some buses hierarchy s
s2 but here's the interesting thing
um assemble prove the beautiful
theorem about the theory
that operates with as
so exist predicates
and the theorem says that if
this is in the theory uh
you could prove that
well the function is definable the
predicate is in and p intercept
currently
so there is also exist and so for all
formulas
and
they equivalently define the predicate
then in fact you get that
the predicate the function isn't
polynomial time which is really
really beautiful result and kind of
surprising
it basically says that if you reason
this np predicates and if you can prove
that something is an np-intercept point
then in fact it must be in polynomial
time
so sort of in the bounded arithmetic
world at least here
the probable np-intercept point p is
polynomial time
the really cool really surprising result
and this naturally generalizes to levels
of polynomial time hierarchy
you could talk about exists for all
exist
a second order and it will give you a
third level and
again you could use the witnessing serum
bus fitness and theorem to capture the
corresponding
um deterministic class
but you may ask the okay with np
predicates we didn't quite capture and
feel
what we really captured is polynomial
time
in the case when the theory could prove
that something is in an intersect
b but can they actually take a logic
corresponding to a complexity class
and get a theory for exactly the same
complexity class
what would it take
uh so before we go that just to quickly
mention for
people who are familiar with uh some
buses theories
um the different the difference here is
that
in our language we only have plus and
times but we do have
um strings so
some already had theories
the second order object he
for p space for exponential time and so
on
and there he used that extra
function in the language in order to
define bigger things
but rasbora and security have shown
that you can uh go back and forth
between the series with one more
extra sword and um
having this smash operator in the
language
so in our setting we don't have any
extra operators
uh and they just have the string sort
and
we get the this is equivalent to s h
okay so uh just to reiterate
how do we get a theory we take axioms
defining basic arithmetic and add an
axiom that says
all objects definable in a certain logic
exist
so um what can we do with it
we could actually extend so um if i
remove
well the series uh
s i2 and ti2 that sambas define
um there you do allow multiplication
on big numbers small numbers so you
generally have multiplication
but in the setting here in the
two-sorted setting
you since you don't have multiplication
of the
larger second order object you could
actually
get a theory for ac 0 but you cannot
do multiplication of your objects and
starting from the theory for ac
0 you could get
a series for all sorts of classes within
polynomial time
and how do you get the theory for each
zero well remember that barnes and
merman and strobin
told us the first order logic
if you have arithmetic in your language
and well you have arithmetic in your
language in
arithmetic captures d log time uniformly
zero so just
define uh our class of formulas to be
uh formulas with non-second order
quantifiers
and uh using beautiful characterization
by error gradle we get a theory for
non-deterministic log space and the
theory for polynomial time
from second order uh existential
to cnn formulas and second order
existential horn formulas respectively
but this correspondence
is not exactly automatic because
remember if we had
np formulas we didn't really
quite get np because polynomial time
and this is really non-trivial result
when do we actually capture precisely
theory
and this depends on how hard it is to
prove
closure properties of the complexity
class
so what do what do i mean by quantum
properties
we would like to work with really nice
complexity classes and nice complexity
class of which
np is not quite are closed under first
order operations
you could take ends and ors and knots
and bounded quantification you can
compose things
and you still remain within the class so
um in particular for np it's a very good
question whether it's
closed under uh negation let alone
whether it's probably close under
negation so
np and classes in the polynomial time
hierarchy
are not really quite robust to get those
kind of results
but polynomial time non-deterministic
lock space non-trivially and
ac0 definitely are and another caveat is
that we really want those properties to
be provable
within the reasoning in the system
so and here it is it's a generic
statement
that if you could actually prove
using reasoning this only concept from
that class
that the class is closed under
first order operations then
um you get a system of arithmetic that
precisely captures this complexity class
as in it proves um totality exactly of
the functions
from this class so this gives you an
automatic way to take
a logic characterization of a complexity
class
whichever one your favorite complexity
class is
and convert it into a theory of
arithmetic
so uh i'm really out of time but let me
just say
for ac 0 it's direct ac 0 is close than
the ac 0
for polynomial time and for nl it's a
bit more work because
you actually need to formalize foreign
satisfiability in the proves that
analytical cornell within and our
reasoning
within polytime reasoning but this can
be done
even trickier class log cfl
sac one was done by satoru roda
and um
and basically the way you do it is you
build the theory
and then you generalize uh
bus fitness and theorem to the new
setting
so just to say that not the only way of
building theories
for example um in their
book they also use an approach
of taking a complete problem for a class
and throwing it in as an
axiom defining axiom for that problem
and then
building theories on that but um
generally at least you could definitely
translate from um
from descriptive complexity okay
um so i'm out of time
so let me just say that this
this talk was mostly kind of a survey
from this week's topic i find models
here in descriptive complexity to next
week's
topics which will um touch upon
many different aspects of reasoning
systems in particular i think systems of
arithmetic
from piano arithmetic to bounded
arithmetics
but hopefully um
here um you could
see how you could go from the power
from the expressive power to reasoning
power
in essentially in one method
okay thank you so much and
any questions comments awesome thank you
for a
beautiful and enlightening talk antenna
thank you very much
questions please
so so i have some comments and uh
questions so
in a different setting i actually study
theories over
arithmetic and strings and i'm surprised
that there is this
uh i wasn't aware of this these theories
over strings and arithmetic that
were defined by cook and others
and i would be happy to chat with you
offline about potential connections
because there are many open questions
there
which have been open for maybe 70 years
or something like that
and i wonder whether any of these
connections can be helpful
in resolving some of those questions
some of them are complexity theoretics
others are more you know decidability
and so on but in any event it would be
interesting to
you know explore those connections um
any additional questions
yeah i have one question about this
sl equals l result so
the existence of expander graphs you do
it with this exact product
there's a kind of zigzag yeah
so which part is missing to get the
formalization
is it wrong yeah what's missing is that
the you could prove the existence of
expanded graphs when you start with
things small things with constant
expansion and you combine them you keep
expansion constant
what you do when you start with
something that does not have a constant
expansion that's what we haven't figured
out
okay thanks
hi antonina uh can you comment on these
two approaches
uh you mentioned like cook new a and uh
your approach using finite model theory
uh so what are the differences between
let's say the theories you get for nl by
doing such things
like is is there an easy way to or are
they exactly the same to prove the same
theorem so what exactly happens
they do prove the same theorems um
i think steel has steven phone having
their book
the connections all the different ways
but
they i think as far as i know they do
prove the same serums
so even the theory operating with
uh horn formula does prove the same
series
as uh tv but interestingly it's much
easier to formalize the recursive
definition
using the whole formula than go the
other way around
any additional questions so i'm trying
to put together a question
for antonita so i was struck by the same
thing that encore mentioned that you
you split your you were categorizing
things that
introduced all functions all at once
versus things that sort of built up to
get all functions i've always
categorized more the first order
theories versus the second order
theories
so we sort of have two two different
viewpoints to this does this mean
there's really three different
ways to set up bound bound arithmetic do
you view it this way
um i'm taking picture of your paper with
steve on chrome and so forth and uh
with um proving so uh proving that and
that nl equals cohen l that's a that's a
different type of bootstrapping you
think than
the things that the theories use
induction
um that's a different type of
bootstrapping um yes
but you you would know much better than
i do what does a different platform
mean i've certainly read all this i just
never it's just you obviously have a
different view
viewpoint of this i was interested to
get your your feeling about this
um so
you can definitely start with um an
axiom
that gives you a totality of for example
graph reachability or circuit evaluation
problem
and builds theory on top of that and you
end up with nice theory
universally axiomatizing everything
and i think you could prove the
equivalence
between this theory and the theory based
on
the descriptive complexity view
and um and the
theories like pv that come from recurve
definitions
as far as i know they're equivalent but
as
there's a very good way of saying that
you did you need a different type of
bootstrapping
in each case
okay good good i guess the other comment
is you
seems seemingly we need to go to the
second order versions of the theories to
deal with these very weak classes like
l and l and n l and so forth and
sac one i suppose and so forth um
i guess just because we get uh ac one
since we don't have multiplication of
the larger objects
right so yeah
and going from descriptive complexity to
second order is a bit more
kind of it's a bit easier than
at least for me to think about because
in descriptive complexity you do have
those
second order objects floating around
okay all right all right thank you
thank you thank you again antonina for a
wonderful talk thank you
so thanks to all the speakers for great
talks today
yes thank you to everybody and i guess
we
will be on the town at least some of us
after this soon yeah all right
so see you tomorrow then bye bye
everybody on gaza town and i don't know
in a second okay
thank you so much thank you fantastic
fantastic talk thanks